So thank you Martin for your willingness to do this interview. A pleasure to do it.
We are in a very special location we are in the heart of Vatican City Why are we here
Well we're here in the Vatican because the Vatican has a Academy of Science called the Pontifical Academy of Sciences which has
conferences on various topics and the members seventy or eighty scientists from all over the world of all faiths
and non so it's a really global academy and we have scientific discussions
but I think one useful thing we can do is address issues of social import where if we can interest the authorities in
the Vatican it can make a difference
and to give one example we had a conference eighteen months ago in May twenty fourteen on sustainability climate
and the environment and this got traction within the Vatican
and it then led to the Papal Encyclical in mid twenty fifteen which of course was a very important influence on the
Paris environmental
and climate conference in December twenty fifteen because of course the pope has immense traction especially in Latin
America Africa and East Asia
and I think the fact that the pope would come out strongly in favor of the importance of concern about climate
and our duties to the environment had a big effect in easing the past a consensus at the Paris conference so that's an
example where the pontifical academy can I think have a more distinctive role than other national academies
but you also have meetings on the cosmology and other subjects like that.
Were you kind of surprised that particular in this kind of climate change debate Pope Francis kind of came out as such
a strong I would almost say voice of reason. In a world that's sometimes very confused.
Well I think it was surprising and gratifying because the other point that came out in that
encyclical was the humanities duty to the environment and of course although
Franciscans have had that view the Church itself has had the line that men have dominion over nature as it were so
the statement fairly clearly that the environment has a value in its own right
and we have an obligation to defend it is something which I think was not clearly apparent in earlier Catholic
statements so not only I would say kind of the environment
and you know human beings taking care of nature there was also a very specific angle in terms of global inequity
and the fact that the poor were mostly affected by these issues Yes Well that's right I think of course the things that
everyone can agree about the church is that it's got a global perspective it thinks long term
and it cares about the world's poor
and in the context of climate change of course the main victims of it will be the poor
and the concern is something which is not short term we're concerned about future generations because they're the ones who
will bear the impact of climate change
and so the church really has all the prerequisites to be a body that can have a real global influence on this debate.
Do you feel any tension between faith and science particularly if you're here.
I don't think there is any tension because of course the Church used to of course be concerned I mean until twenty five
years ago it wasn't good to talk too much about Galileo but things have changed completely now
and the church is very happy to engage in debates on
Issues like evolution
and cosmology etc and I am a cosmologist so they're quite happy to talk about the big bang. So talking about the big bang and cosmology
It's kind of striking that one of the previous presidents of this Academy:
George Lemaitre he was both an ordained priest
but he was also in some sense the father of the expanding universe and the big bang.
So that's something that's perhaps that's a surprise for people to hear it is surprising
and he was in fact a remarkable scientist who started in Cambridge at MIT and then he worked at Louvain.
In Belgium his career and he became president of this academy
but he was indeed one of the early people who applied Einstein's theory to models of the universe
and had the idea of a big bang which he called the primeval atom and he thought very deeply about these questions
and came up with models which are still part of the.
Folklore of the subject as it were and Einstein did not like his ideas in the beginning
no it Einstein actually was rather reluctant to accept all the most exciting
conclusions of his theory he never liked black holes for instance
but he didn't like the idea of the expanding universe he wanted a static universe
and also he although he introduced this thing called the cosmic constant which is a latent force in
empty space he didn't like it and then Lemaitre tried to argue that it was some effect that might be genuine
and Lemaitre turned out to be right because
one of the great discoveries of the last fifty years has been that this force in empty space does exist and is very important for
the future of the universe. So what do you think of the fact that Einstein was clearly very brilliant.
But in some sense could you say that his theory was even more clever than he was? It was because Einstein of course through his
huge insight developed this theory but its consequences took decades to be fully.
Understood and things like black holes the Big Bang
and gravitational waves which are regarded now as the great confirmatory tests of the theory in all three cases
Einstein was negative or ambivalent
and also in all three cases it's only recently that we got convincing evidence can you say something about the state
of cosmology if you really think about it in terms of a long term development I mean human kind has been thinking about
the cosmos for
millenia Yes Yes But what's happening right at this moment? Well of course it is interesting as you say that
Einstein's theory was special and he was uniquely original as a scientist because he came up with this theory.
As a result mainly of pure thought it was not stimulated by puzzling experiments. Did it come like a hundred years too early
Yes fifty years too early had it not been for Einstein then the theory would not have been
developed for decades and indeed it was not untill the nineteen sixtees.
That astronomers found the first entities in the universe where Einstein's effect was important well than just
being a tiny correction to Newton's theory in the nineteen sixties.
We found objects called neutron stars. stars the matter of some
but squeezed down into that down if you have a few kilometers
and also black holes objects which had collapsed cutting everything off of the rest of the universe
but leaving a gravitational imprint frozen in space where they left and evidence for these things emerged in the sixty's
and seventy's
and also evidence emerged that our universe had evolved from some very dense hot state this was so-called background
radiation which fills the universe and is a relic of the hot dense beginnings of the universe
and this is what Lemaitre had speculated about much earlier but the evidence came in the sixty's
so from the sixty's onwards.
there were phenomena which required Einstein's theory in order to interpret them properly
and so the theory changed from being rather sort of backwater out of the mainstream of physics to being one of the
real frontiers of theoretical physics. I read somewhere in a obituary of Einstein that at the time of his death in
1955 people admired his work as a great piece of art which is something for scientists it's quite a quite a
putdown right because you don't want to be a you want to actually be a theory of the world of the Universe yes
but it was a great piece of creative thinking of course
there's a lot of discussion about creativity in the sciences versus in the arts of course most creativity in the
arts is more distinctive but in the sciences
and Einstein was more creative in that he made more difference normally in science if A didn't do something B.
Would do it very quickly.
That was true of quantum theory - that was more a collective effort. Yes
but in the case of Einsteins relativity if he hadn't done it then the idea would not have emerged for decades
particular I think for general relativity. That's right
and one of my favorite scientific writers Peter Medawar who is.
who is a great biologist and he put this rather well he said the difference between the arts
and sciences are like this that if you are doing science then if you don't discover something then someone else will
discover the same thing soon whereas when Wagner was.
In the middle of the ring cycle he took ten years off to write Tristan and Meistersingers
and he didn't think anyone would scoop him on Gotterdammerung
and so I think there's a difference that in the arts your work is individualistic even though it doesn't last whereas
in the sciences your work is durable is part of some growing edifice but it loses
its individuality and if you hadn't done it then someone else would have done it fairly soon
and Einstein is perhaps one of the few exceptions in that he did make a more distinctive imprint on twentieth century
science than anyone else
and one thing that is just fascinating I sometimes use the metaphor of finding the beginning of a roll of scotch tape
you know which is very difficult and then you can unroll it is yes
and so if you think of this unrolling tape particular for cosmology which is now.
Like a hundred years since Einstein's work on general relativity we have this explosion of results of ideas where are we
so to say in understanding the big picture do you feel we are just at the beginning we're half way what's your
feeling
well of course we are always at the beginning of science because as the frontiers advance their periphery gets longer
and a new set of questions comes in. Particular about understanding the fundamental principles of the universe Yes Well I think
people made huge progress certainly since I was a student forty years ago
when we didn't know if there's a big bang at all one thing we've learned of course is that the universe in the
scales that we can observe does have a certain uniformity yes we've learned that the atoms in a distant galaxy are just
the same as the atoms in the lab. were that not the case of course the universe would be anarchic we would not make any
progress at all but we've learned about that we've also learned that all the galaxies in the universe
and all the stars can be traced back to a common origin in this hot dense beginning the so-called big bang
and we can now date that to being thirteen point eight billion years ago
and so we can trace out the history of the universe from the hot dense beginning to the present
and we can also understand how from these amorphous beginnings the first structures formed as the universe cooled down
and condensed into the first galaxies and stars.
And we have a very good theory for this
and we can actually test the theory a number of ways we can look back with our telescopes to objects so far away
that their light set out when the universe was a tenth of its present age
and we have evidence of the much earlier universe from studying in detail this background radiation to the beginning
and we get a very consistent picture going back to when the universe was smooth apart from tiny fluctuations
and to the stage when those fluctuations have enhanced their density contrast to make again galaxies
and this is a consistent picture
and it also tells us that the universe contains the ordinary atoms that we know about
and also contains about five times as much stuff in the form of what's called dark matter. particles which have no
electric charge and don't interact much as they move around under gravity we don't know what particles they are they're still a
mystery but we know for sure that the dynamics of galaxies is dominated by this dark matter.
Are you personally surprised that we came so far that we have such a complete picture of.
The universe I mean you could imagine
there are just formidable obstacles in learning about our own universe well I think it is it is gratifying in a surprising
number of ways first of course we owe the advances ninety five percent to improvements in technology
and instrumentation. arm chair theory doesn't get you very far by itself. none of us are as wise as Einstein we got
further because we had better instruments. and he didn't even believe his own consequences of his theory only after
experimental evidence Yes that's right became it clear for him too yes that's right
but I think that a more fundamental level what is gratifying is that our minds which haven't changed very much since
our ancestors roamed the African savannahs tens of thousands of years ago.
Can cope not just with the everyday world that we evolved to cope with
but can cope with the counter intuitive world of the quantum
and also of the cosmos so it's surprising that the world is such that we can understand both the micro
and the cosmic. what we have not yet quite understood is how to link those together as you know better than me the
challenge of twenty first century physics is to have a unified theory which combines what Einstein did which gives us a
good picture of the large scale universe and gravity with the quantum world. Are you optimistic that this will proceed
or you are you expecting at some point there will be a sign forbidden for human beings.
Well. for human scientists
well you can judge far better than me how likely it is that string theory will deliver the goods or that some other theory
will. I think it's very good that there were some people who believed that this may happen because otherwise they wouldn't be motivated
to try if they're not motivated they would never succeed so it's very good that there are people including many of our friends
and colleagues who are working on ideas of Unified Theories and I hope they will succeed
but I think we have to be open minded about whether there are deep aspects of reality which are going to be beyond our
capacity to grasp because after all I mean a monkey can't understand quantum theory and there may be some
Deep features of reality which we just can't comprehend. we are as hopeless as monkeys to get there. You think that we will ever
discover these things or that they are almost by definition outside our realm because monkeys probably will also not lament
that they can't understand quantum mechanics. Well that's right we are not aware of these things
but there may be aspects of nature which we are not aware of
and that of course may mean that there are discoveries to be left to.
Brains better than ours some kind of post human entities which may come into existence one day. We'll come to that. Clearly though
this is quite amazing this is. Human beings on planet Earth.
Looking at the universe. Do you think there is science elsewhere in the universe?
Scientists elsewhere? well of of course we don't know I mean I think we can say more in answer to that question
than we could have done twenty years ago because one thing we've certainly learnt which is a great discovery in the last
twenty years is that most of the stars which we see are orbited by
retinues of planets just as the sun is orbited by the earth and the other familiar planets
and it's quite likely that in our Milky Way galaxy there are a billion planets rather like the earth
like the Earth in a sense they are about the size of the earth
and at the distance from their parent star such that water can exist neither boiling away
nor staying frozen. So they are as comfortable to our kind of life. Right as potential habitats
but of course being habitable is not the same as being inhabited
and of course one of the key scientific questions which is not understood yet
is the origin of life even on Earth I mean we understand how from this simplest organisms over three
and a half billion years or so.
our biosphere of which we are a part has emerged
but what is still not understood is the actual origin the transition from complex chemistry to the first metabolizing
replicating structures and that's one of these problems everyone has known is important
but it's been put in the as it were too difficult box. it's very difficult to say of course
but do you feel this is a problem that it's kind of it's foreseeable that say within the next decades we make a breakthrough. I think it is
yes because I think unlike the past now there are serious people working on it .
So I'm hopeful that within ten
or twenty years we will understand how that key transition from biochemistry to the first replicating metabolizing
structures happened I think we will understand that because it's no longer thought premature
and so chemists aided by experiments and computer experiments are making progress and of course
when we understand that which of course is an exciting discovery for even the most earthbound biologist it will tell us two
things it will tell us Was it a rare fluke or would this have happened in some other planet like the earth
because life originated remarkably fast after the moment it was possible. it seems simple life did
multicellular life took longer and that of course does indicate that it wasn't a rare fluke and did happen
and so we will understand that
but another thing we might understand ten twenty years from now is whether the chemical basis of all life on earth
D.N.A.
and RNA and all that is sort of uniquely special
or whether there could be life out there which could be quite different yes could there even be methane-based life on
Titan which is a moon of Jupiter. Of Saturn. And it is exciting that again we are in a position that some of these questions
can be asked and answered experimentally. Well that's right because
well we can't quite do it yet within ten years we have telescopes powerful enough to actually take the spectrum of the
light from a planet around another star and get some feel for is there oxygen there is the surface green
and things like that so we will learn whether there is vegetation
or life of some kind some kind of photosynthesis going on on these other planets around other stars
and that will be a huge discovery. I know that as a scientist you have to you you're very much aware of all the uncertainties
and that experiments will tell us what. but as a cosmologist if you think about the cosmos
What is your personal kind of I would almost say gut feeling
what is your personal intuition you think that the universe is populated. Also with intelligent life?
Well I think we know so little that it is it would be foolish to lay. yes OK
but leaving that aside I mean I think if you asked me to bet yes I would bet that sort of simple life is probably
widespread but of course going from simple life to
Life like us which are self-aware
and intelligent we don't know how likely that was because evolutional biologists debate about the contingencies that were
involved in our emergence they ask the questions the critical points where in some sense life has to go over a certain threshold
that's right and you know if the dinosaurs had not been wiped out you know would
intelligence have developed somewhere else or were these contingencies crucial so we did
and if evolution were rerun on the earth then would it end up the same or would it end up quite different
and so that's an uncertainty which means that even if the simple life we don't know.
How likely it is that it would evolve into anything that became intelligent but then of course there's another question
because one thing which astronomy does tell us is that the time lying ahead exactly is at least as long as the time that
elapsed up till now our sun has been shining for four and a half billion years
but it will be about six billion before it flares up and engulfs the inner planets and wipes out
any life remaining on the earth
and so no astronomer could really believe that we humans are the culmination of evolution.
So it continues. it continues and we have no idea of what's going to happen I mean if we if we.
Think of what might happen on the earth then of course the pessimistic outcome is we wipe ourselves out
but the more optimistic scenario is that the developement continues
but if development continues beyond humans like us it won't be Darwinian selection it will be.
Controlled technology driven evolution by future developers in gene editing and also cyborgs
and artificial intelligence
Can we talk a little bit about that. I think that is a very interesting phase that our civilization is. You know technology
was always around yes but you can definitely say that now it's kind of growing.
Exponentially fast
and I want to come to the topic where I feel personally that we are moving away from a phase where we understood
basically the building blocks of matter and life
and perhaps the universe towards a phase where we start kind of rearranging these building blocks right now so you
already mentioned. We understood living organisms but I think now in the lab we try to create parts or perhaps whole.
Living cells and so you feel this is kind of in some sense a phase transition this is a radical change
I think that this century is special for a number of reasons it's the first when we could.
Create species quite different from anything that now exists it's the first where maybe artificial intelligence electronic
intelligence may start to compete with the level of intelligence in the hardware in our skulls
and it's also of course the century
when for the first time life can spread from the Earth to other places in the solar system so this is a special century
even in the cosmic
Perspective where there have been forty five million centuries already since the earth formed
and there will be at least that number in the future so this century is very special
and can you say something about what you see as future developments not in many many centuries
but say for instance the next next decades because some of these developments are going incredibly fast
and perhaps we are not even the general public is not even aware what is possible right now so for instance thinking both of life
and intelligence How do you see this happening in the coming coming years how will it impact us
well I am not an expert on either of these topics but I think right but
but I think it's clear that our understanding of genetics and our ability to actually synthesize new genomes
and modify existing genomes is developing very fast to the extent it will be possible to almost design new species
or design very heavily modified species and adapt our progeny
and that's going to happen in parallel there is another quite separate development which is.
the advance in computers from being just calculating machines to being.
Objects which can undertake what's called generalized machine learning and we've seen developments of this and
spectacular .. well indeed
and of course to think of some key steps in this it's twenty years since a computer beat Kasparov the world chess
champion.
And that was done by a program being made by expert chess players etc
and the computer could work through millions of moves fast
but we taught the computer how to play chess. what happened this year was a computer
beat the world's champion in the game of Go and this is another very challenging game
more challenging yes but the big difference was in this case
and the computer was not programmed in detail
and it was a really given the general rules then it watched hundreds of thousands of games
and then played against itself and got better so the people who devised the program they didn't understand why it made
some particular clever moves which enabled it to beat the world champion
and so this is an example where the computer is sort of teaching itself by being able to crunch huge amounts of data
and in the same way translation is now done not by giving the computer the details of vocabulary and syntax
but by getting it to read millions of pages
and then if they give it millions of pages of European Union documents of different languages it never gets bored it just reads
all of these kind and eventually learns to translate. it's a perfect civil servant. that's right so this
generalized machine learning is. Are you worried about the fact that these machines who beat people at Go
or in language skills they're basically not able to tell us how they did this right I mean they are not able to instruct us
they just intuitively learn how to do this
in fact in the way a child learns to speak a language you can speak a language
but you're not able to write down the grammar Yes yes Are you  worried about that when machines are doing more
and more of that stuff which is really extremely convenient that they are kind of autonomous that they just go their own ways
well I think there is a worry because there's some things which they will be able to do better than humans like
well
well already the the way the quantitative hedge funds steal money of us is by being able to analyze more data than the
human being can and of course that's going to get better
and better as they can see tiny correlations They will take advantages of our weaknesses. that's right they are doing that already
but they do it to a greater extent. but I think we got to bear in mind that still they don't really have.
Human level general intelligence to do some things and of course.
The whole point is that robots are still clumsy I mean they can't move around the pieces on a real chessboard
as well as a child can so there's a long way to go before machines can actually interact with the external world. One thing
I liked of this.
Game Go game between the computer and the. that the fifth game actually was won by the Go champion because he felt.
I'm not going to win I have to do some crazy stuff so he actually did something so this fifth game might be
something that somehow brought out the unique human qualities well that's right a human is more flexible and
and of course there are many things which.
machines can't do
but of course the problem as I understand it it's going to be to ensure that machines have common sense because there
are many things that we understand. About the world for instance I was told that the. Computer that had beaten the.
The American champion in this.
TV game called jeopardy. Watson. yes and I did not know this game
but it is less mindless than most computer than most T.V.
Games but it was asked a question which is bigger: a shoe box or mount Everest
and it couldn't say because it has no conception. It could be a gigantic cosmic shoe box.
it had no conception of the every day world
and another simple example it's given is that if you have  one of these robots in your home which is supposed to sort
of make sure that your fridge is stored up and the heating is on and the food is ready for you when you come home you know.
If it's run out of meat it may put the cat in the oven you know because it may not realise that this
is something not appropriate and so. the chicken in the oven is fine. yes
but right so one of the issues really for the people developing AI is to ensure that it does learn what human ethics
and human attitudes are. intelligent enough to be able to learn those sorts of things. I know when
Garry Kasparov was asked you know when he lost this game this chess game against a computer that's you know it's
not man against machine but he said well it's me
and the machine to against somebody else so yes in some sense is that a better image in our mind that we
should kind of start to collaborate with these machines
I think so because I think Kasparov says that a human plus a machine is best
and I think that's going to be the habit but there's are these nightmare scenarios of the machines taking over
and of course the kind of thing which I think is not too futuristic is if we have a system of a city where all the
public services and the transport is controlled in some smart way and the whole thing could go wrong
so we're very vulnerable and one of the downsides of course of all these developments and indeed of the modern
interconnected world is that we are more vulnerable because everything is interconnected. just we go there in a
moment
but if you think about this issue of. we talked about nature about the origins of life the cosmic evolution Yes
Now we are developing technology again from a cosmic perspective.
Is there do you see a difference between what nature is doing what we're doing
Well I think in a sense we're going to take over from nature because if we think of what may happen not
in the next fifty years but maybe in the next. Two or three hundred years then it may well be that humans.
turned into sort of cyborgs or that the electronic machines take over completely because obviously.
They don't have all the features of the human brain but they have the advantage of speed compared to the human brain
and so it could be that the future will lie with.
Electronic machines not organic creatures like us
and I personally think if you ask me my most likely scenario for the next hundred years I think that.
There there will be in a hundred years a few people living on Mars and they will be people who.
are real adventurers that have to cope with a very hostile.
Climate
and conditions. old fashioned explorers. yes right but they're in an environment for which their bodies are ill
adapted
and I think they will use all the technology we will then have to adapt to that new environment whether that will be by
Cyborg techniques by downloading their brains into a machine or something like that
and I think it will happen there because we're probably going to want to control for ethical or prudential reasons the
adoption of these technologies here on Earth where as if you have these people beyond the range of any such regulation
you would wish them good luck
in proving this there they got the biggest motivation But my scenario would be that within a few hundred years there
will be.
Entities that we would call post human in that they would be very different from us so they'd be a new species and if they are.
Electronic
and not organic then of course they may not want to be on a planet at all they may be happier under zero gravity
somewhere else and that will be the future.
And so if you then think in terms of the cosmic perspective of time
when there are millions of centuries ahead then the way things will look is that we had forty five million centuries
and then for a few tens or hundreds of centuries organic civilization evolved developed technology
and then it was taken over by machines and they have billions of years billions of centuries ahead
and so this has an implication also if we are thinking there might be intelligent life elsewhere in the universe
I mean as I said I think there will be probably simple life but if it is intelligent life will be
and I think if we detect any kind of evidence for something artificial.
Beyond our solar system then it is more likely to be these machines because if the evolution on this other planet
had tracked what happened on the earth then it's unlikely to be synchronized
if they are a billion years behind then. because there is only this brief window in some sense where nature
and technology are working at the same time which is our current age. Yes that's right if
if they're behind us then there would be no evidence for any technology if they're ahead of us then they will have got way into
this machine age and so I think it would be unlikely that we would detect any other.
External Intelligence which is anywhere like us so I think the normal talk about you know these
aliens who are sort of bipeds with eyes on stalks maybe that that's not realistic. All unnecessary.
This phase that we are currently in is just a phase of the evolution of life which is necessary to spread from planet earth
through the universe. it's only through technology that we can actually really spread around.
That's right because clearly as humans we're not adapted to  long voyages whereas if you're a machine near immortal then these long
and distant voyages if you want to make them are going to be possible but of course this leads to another.
Point. the famous Fermi paradox which is that if indeed life on earth was not unique then why haven't we seen
evidence for the aliens which had a head start over us and if it indeed is a serious constraint
and just does lead me to suspect that perhaps intelligent life is rare and if that's the case of course then it.
Makes what happens here on earth even more important because it clearly matters to us as human beings
but it could be cosmically important because in this century.
What happens will determine whether life takes its next step
and jump starts post human evolution away from the earth and in inorganic form or whether we sort of snuff things out
or go back to the Stone Age
and that would foreclose these potentials for what might happen in the far future. Martin thinking about this
Phase where technology is becoming more important it might even be
taking over what we do here how do you see this from the point of view of evolution is this another phase in evolution
it is a different kind because we've evolved from simple life through Darwinian selection over three
and a half billion years but ofcourse for human beings Darwinian selection has stopped anyway
but future evolution will be technological it will be through modifying the genome
and cyborg technology where we plug into machines etc and so.
This will happen in a directed way on the technological time scale
and therefore much faster because in Darwinian selection it takes about a million years for a species to fully evolve and
go extinct Where as changes to humanity and the emergence of post humans could take just centuries.
Talking about centuries you wrote a book with the title Our Final Century I think in the U.K.
It was Our Final Hour or the other way round. The other way around. the americans like instant gratification and reverse so. An hour.
but it's.
There you talked about the dangers that are coming with these rapid developments in technology can you say
something about what you see as the dangers
and why is this particular century this twenty first century so crucial yes well I think there are two kinds of dangers which
are new to us this century One is that we are collectively putting graver pressures on the environment which then while others
each of us more demanding of energy resources and that is why we worry about climate change. Loss of biodiversity.
And issues like that. is that dangerous to the planet or is it dangerous to us. it's dangerous to us I mean not to the
planet the planet will survive yes
but maybe in a depleted state because if biodiversity is reduced it will be a less exciting
but it happened before this massive extinction Yes that's right so they may have to start again from an early stage
so one class of threats are those we are causing collectively But the other kind which I focused on a bit more in my book
are the threats that
emerge from powerful technologies which empower individuals or small groups of course we had the nuclear weapons
which are the outcome of twentieth century technology which of course changed the global political scene
but. Which was also a pretty close call.
it was a very close call yes. if you would rerun history it's not obvious that we would survive again. absolutely we were just
as McNamara said they were lucky as well as wise at the time of Cuba yes and then we might be less lucky next time
and of course that threat is just in abeyance because we could imagine a new standoff between new super powers
had less Luckily than the Cuba crisis so that's one threat
but I think twenty first century technologies face us with new threats in particular biotechnology because
biotechnology of course is very powerful but we could now edit a genome
and there's something called gain-of-function technology where you can make say the influenza virus more virulent
and more transmissible and these techniques are widely understood biohacking is even a students sport in some places
and they don't need huge special purpose facilities so whereas you can monitor the misuse of nuclear technology
you can't make an H. bomb
in your garage as it were and it's very hard to monitor the misuse of bio and cyber
and that's what worries me that by error or by terror then a small group
or even an individual could cause some sort of global disaster. what about the whole realm of information
and the way we are sharing information our communication technology perhaps also intelligent networks. what do you feel about
well we are vulnerable of course because we depend on global networks for manufacturing etc and this
financial system etc And we know that cyber attacks can already be very serious for these
and that's going to be aggravated I think as time goes on as we become more dependent on information
technology
and networks. Do you feel we are in a certain kind of arms race with technology between kind of the good and the bad applications
because many of these issues you mention need again technology to control. well
They do indeed it's a kind of an arms race
and I think the worry I have is that it's not obvious that the good side is going to win
and I think we can predict unfortunately a growing tension between.
Freedom privacy and security. yes. if we are to avoid the misuse
and I worry not so much about organized state actors as about individual disaffected groups
and my worst nightmare for instance would be someone who was an ecology fanatic who thought there are too many human beings in
the world
and someone with those attitudes combined with fanaticism might say well let's cut down the number of human beings in the world by
releasing some engineered virus. Technologically this is feasible. It's becoming feasible yes. Do you feel is this
is this a purely technological matter or is there also some kind of a moral dimension to it.
Well obviously it would be immoral to do anything like that
but can we do something there also as scientists. Yes Well I think obviously politicians have an extra incentive to minimize
the number of disaffected people with grievances
who are just the kind of people who would do this so the challenge on politicians is much greater because a small minority which
could be overwhelmed by traditional power and they can of course fight back using these technologies
and I think this is a real problem but as regards what scientists can do as such I think scientists.
They're not tremendously wise forecasters always but they can look ahead a bit more
and foresee what are going to be the threats indeed the book I wrote thirteen years ago I'm glad it stood up quite well
in that sense but I think we can foresee what the threats are going to be
and perhaps distinguish better than lay people.
Between what is science fiction and what is something we need to worry about. is it just sketching scenarios
or is it also taking the next step
and perhaps try to convince people to take a certain direction. Well I think it's trying to convince people and politicians
and here again I think we've got to think that. scientists have an advantage because their work is more global
they're more international even in the depths of the Cold War there were fairly open links between scientists
on either side of the iron curtain so science is a global culture which transcends all barriers of faith
and nationality more easily than other cultures so we have that advantage and we share common attitudes
and we can advise our governments
but I think you've got to bear in mind that most of the decisions which politicians have to take.
Involve some science whether they are energy health environment etc
but they're not just science So they have to combine the various components. that's right
and of course on those other components scientists are just citizens they have no special right to be heard
and that's why I think it's very important that.
All citizens should have enough feeling for science and probability
and risk of things like that so they can't be bamboozled too easily by experts
and that they could take part in the debate. if you look at this kind of conversation between science and society
you might argue even looking back on 2016
it was not such a good year for reason. right. so are we losing that debate.
I'm not sure I think the challenges are getting harder but I think.
In an issue where science is an important component like climate change. Energy Policy. health.
Use of genetics. I think we're doing not too badly
but I think the important thing to realize is that scientists can't themselves decide
and here scientists could probably have more influence not by talking directly to a politician or a minister
but through influencing the public consensus because politicians they could dismiss experts
but they can't so easily dismiss something which is in the press every day or which is in their inbox every day from the public
so you mean engaging the public at large. Yes engaging the public at large is a prerequisite for these science related issues to stay on
the agenda especially when they're long term and global like climate change
and environmental energy so I think that's crucially important and
and I think if the public doesn't understand the basics of science then this debate can't really get beyond slogans
and the public can't really be informed citizens. Do you feel that we also should be able to share some of the values of
science and.
Actually what are the values of science for you personally Well of course the values are fairly limited in the sense.
of honesty
and curiosity etc So I don't think there are many values which a scientist needs to have which are not also demanded of other
professionals but I think in science there is this tradition of transnational contacts and open debate
and willingness to be proved wrong and I think we should encourage those use
and also a feeling of probabilities because one of the difficulties in public discourse is that people don't distinguish between
something which is so unlikely that it's not worth worrying about
and things which are worth worrying about because even if unlikely they are so catastrophic.
If they happen that we need to be concerned about them. So one thing I'm personally worried about is there's kind of this
paradox that when science or technology is progressing we learn more
and more the things we learn are kind of quite detailed and technical
almost by definition they are because they're new they are not easy to understand. on the other hand all the
applications of science are more
and more in our lives. so science in the one hand it's kind of moving away from us because of increased complexity
on the other hand it's coming closer because of its relevance So how do we deal with it. how can we make
people understand science if on the other hand only a few individuals might actually fully understand all the details
Yes well I think with difficulty
but I think it's not quite that bad because even though the technical details the mathematics etc of some of the
science we do is very hard for the non specialists to understand I think it is possible to get over the key ideas fairly free of
technicalities I think we can. You are a master of this with cosmology. Well we try it is
difficult
and in fact it's more difficult than people realize because you have to obviously avoid too much mathematics Yes
and you have to avoid technical words You are not a hundred percent truthful
it is very difficult to be honest totally honest sharing your results yes but
but you've got to simplify obviously but hopefully in a honest way
and as Einstein or Bohr said you should make things as simple as possible but no simpler and that's that's a good rule
but I think from my own experience of doing this I think I managed to understand you've got to avoid mathematics
and technical words but there is one particularly difficult thing to avoid which is every day words being used in a special
context and let me give you two examples one is the word
degenerate Yes which we know has a particular meaning in mathematics. A negative meaning.
In mathematics it has
In mathematics it has a tactical meaning a line is a degenerate case of a triangle etc.
and another example which comes up in climate change is. is feedback because if you want to say that.
As the earth warms then it may release methane from the tundra. And it makes things worse.
and it is positive feedback We use the word positive feedback where to most people positive feedback
sounds like what happens after you've had a job appraisal you come out well so positive feedback sounds as a good thing
you did a great job. so that's an example of where the technical phrase can be misunderstood so we got to be careful about
avoiding using everyday words in a sense which is different from. It's like a medical test that comes out
negative which is a good thing. that's right yes. so talking about kind of science
and being a scientist. What would you say are some of the qualities successful qualities that a
What are some of the qualities that a scientist should have or can have.
Well obviously the ability to understand some technical details or certain mathematical skills
and now of course computer skills as well.
But also I suppose the motive to try and understand something
and accept that most of your early ideas are going to be wrong
and also accept that there are some problems which you will never solve I think one of the differences between
lay people and experts is that.
Lay people don't realize that some problems are really too difficult to solve I mean and.
The balance between what is easy and what is difficult is rather surprising. I could give you an example from my own field astronomy
that I expect people to believe me if I tell them about what happens when two black holes a billion lightyears
Away collide with each other and that we got evidence for that
but on the other hand you are foolish to believe any experts on child care
or diet which are things that everyone cares about
and understands
and that's because it's a fallacy to think that every day problems are the easy problems they are also the hardest problem
anything to do with human beings is far harder to understand than any things in the inanimate world
and it's a fallacy to think that they are easy to understand just like people sometimes say that.
It should be easier to cure the common cold than other diseases just because it's common
but that doesn't mean it. so people don't have a feeling for what can be done and what can't be
and of course one of the knacks of being a scientist is to choose a topic to work on which is not trivial
nor on the other hand so intractable that you won't make any progress at all. So talking about the motivation of scientists I
think these motivations come in. Various kind of flavors.
Some people want to understand the world others want to change it. how do you see this.
Well I think as human beings we want to change the world but our understanding is separate from that
but I think among scientists there is a great variety of mental types
and I've been surprised by this because you know my professional life like yours is lived among a fairly homogeneous
group of people with many common interests
but even among them I think we see quite a variety of personality types in those who think pictorially
and those who think in terms of equations those who like computers those who don't like computers
and also those who like to solve problems in a sort of step by step piecemeal way and those who are happy to sort of.
think in a more open ended way What do you think is the role  of imagination in science.
I think imagination is crucial
but it's sort of constrained imagination it's not quite like art. Well perhaps is rather like sort of
composing in a fugue or writing a sonnet where you're trying to do something creative but within a standard form
and so science is something where.
Any idea has to be embedded in the huge edifices already built up by your predecessors
but clearly you've got to make some insights.
And unless you make some new insight then
all you do is going to add something which anyone else could have done as well. Rick Feynman said science is
creativity in a straitjacket. Yes. What about playing playfulness. Well I think that is part of it
I think Feynman also said that you got to keep some childhood instincts alive and if I think of
one of the most creative scientists I know who is Roger Penrose he's a good example of someone who
thinks very visually He thinks not only deeper than the rest of us but more differently more pictorial than most of us
and he's an example of someone whose recreations of being creative in thinking of his tiling and antagonal
or quasi Crystal patterns and also he
and his father who was a psychologist invented these impossible figures which inspired Escher who already knew to devise
some of his new new dials on the endless staircase etc So Penrose is an example of someone who you can't really meet without
recognizing
as someone who is especially creative in a sort of playful way as well as obviously a very deep way. I think this famous
quote of Einstein basically.
to the effect that imagination is more important than knowledge because imagination is capturing everything that is yet to
be known. So do you feel that in some sense we also have to be made aware of the opportunity to
understand something that there are certain questions that perhaps you know current generations aren't even aware is a
question that could be answered
well I think that's true that you've got to be aware of some problems which have become tractable and become timely
and work on them but at the same time you don't want to work on something which is impossible
but I think one thing which has happened
and this is perhaps something which is a downside of being a scientist is that science has become a much larger
enterprise with more mixed motives involved
and the number of new insights has sadly not gone up in proportion to the number of people who would call themselves
scientists and that's partly because science is.
Becoming more tactical more detailed needs bigger equipment etc but partly also because there are more commercial pressures
etc so it makes it different. What about the social elements to it I think these days I think you can probably argue that
being a scientist is much more well the interconnectivity of science
and the fact that collaborations are becoming larger Do you see there another development.
Well of course the type of science which is done if you're in a big team is different
and you know it's certainly true that many people who have been original scientists worked in the primary stage of a
subject they would not like to be part of the group at CERN where you are one of a thousand people who are working on a big
experiment that's a quasi industrial organization
and I think one has to warn young people that if they want.
to do science they've got to realize that some kind of science is like being in the industry with some of the downsides
without some of the benefits where as some allows you to be more individual
and to make your own reputation independent of. What about the  global element you know we are here in the Vatican
but we have colleagues all over the world.
Do you see some kind of convergence happening if you look at science across the globe Well I think
the benign change is that science is being done more globally I mean it used to be done mainly in North America
and Europe where as now the rise of science in Asia and other parts of the world is surely benign
and I think we must except that the hegemony of the Western world which has existed for four hundred years is
going to end because it's going to be in Asia that the world's economic
and intellectual capital is going to be concentrated from now on and so it's going to get more global
but of course the problems which science needs to tackle are very often global problems
and so it's very appropriate that scientists should collaborate with people all across the world in dealing with the
energy resources
and climate Do you see there's truly one global community There certainly is because some scientists ofcourse I am part of
it yes
but I think clearly the scientists who we have at Vatican meetings who work on the environment or on health care etc They're
part of some global community and what they care about are global problems
and the key thing is to ensure that their voice spreads beyond academia to those who can really change the world
thinking about. coming back again to your own field cosmology so let's kind of zoom out
and looking at the universe and we see here planet earth and we have this group of scientists.
Trying to understand well the planet ourselves but also the universe.
How do you see us from a cosmic perspective what are we exactly doing here on this planet.
Well ofcourse we don't know I think the more one understands about any phenomenon the more amazed one is by it I mean
I think.
When I look at an insect now I'm more amazed by an insect
when I realize all the chemical processes that have to happen if it's just simply to move his leg you know
and one realizes how amazingly intricate the natural world is and in that sense the physical world of stars
and galaxies is simpler than the biological world but of course it's got this sort of scale
and I think it's been a privilege to be working in a subject where our perspective has changed
and expanded in a few decades and of course.
We've really had revolutions going back to the Copernican Revolution originally when we realized the Earth wasn't the center
and then we realized that our sun was just one star in the galaxy
and then our galaxy is just one of billions you can see with a large telescope
and I think we are now perhaps going to be due for a fourth Copernican Revolution
when we will learn that physical reality is much more extensive than the domain we can see with even our biggest
telescopes because we can see with our biggest telescopes out to sort of horizon which is limited to the distance of light
kind of travelled to us from since the Big Bang
but there's nothing physically real about that horizon anymore than there is about the horizon around you if you are in a boat
in the middle of the ocean you don't think that the ocean ends beyond that and there are good reasons to think that the.
Universe extends probably at least a thousand times further than we can see and probably much much more than that
And that's not all because that's all.
The aftermath of our big bang and then the other question is whether our Big Bang is the only one
and there is a popular idea called the multiverse whether there is variance according to which there may be zillions of
other big bangs of which ours is just one
and that they may all be governed by different physical laws from ours we don't know so it could be that there is an
ecology of Cosmoses on a scale far bigger than what we can observe so our perception of overall physical
reality is rather like the perception of a plankton in a spoonful of water of the entire earth you know we are very
limited. take this perspective which is all kind of making us kind of less special Yes On the other hand in the
beginning of our conversation we talked about the special nature of life on Earth we don't know how special it is
the fact that we have intelligent life and the fact that we have life that is intelligent enough to look at the universe
and have thoughts exactly like this so the title of this series we've chosen the mind of the universe.
Perhaps we should have said a mind of the universe which is this special role of us on planet Earth because.
Certainly I think this is one of the few places perhaps the only one we don't know where these kind of thoughts as
you just kind of shared are generated yes so again looking at this vast hierarchy
And our little little you say a little plankton in a drop of water in a huge ocean.
What is that special role we have in observing all of that yes.
Well it we clearly are special in being able to at least grasp the glimmerings of these huge ideas
and it may be that post human intelligence is needed to grasp it more fully but clearly.
Even though we don't know how common life is it's clear that we are living on a special planet this pale blue dot in
the cosmos and it's also equally clear although less well appreciated
that we are living on it in a special time. this century is very special it's the first
when one species namely the human species can determine the planet's fate and also this is a century when we can perhaps.
Start a transition to a completely different form of intelligence based on electronics and machines
and perhaps spread beyond the Earth so this century is special so if you think of a space
and time diagram you know this little dot in space and time is very special
and if we spread around we could be actually could be the mind of the universe Well our descendants could be yes
yes. thank you very much.